them Joan Murtaugh was facing a horrific
future diagnosed with Alzheimer's
disease she knew she would forget
everything and every person in her life
eventually and it would likely lead to
her death
but then a first she got into a clinical
trial that offered hope sometimes
there's a word or something that I'm
trying to recall and I'm not I can't
think of it but now if I just give it a
minute it pops into my head it's so good
I mean it just feels so good
you know I don't think I was probably
able to do that earlier
the drug lechembe has been approved for
people with early onset Alzheimer's it's
an injection of a lab-made protein that
targets the buildup of the protein
amyloid which could be a cause of the
disease but the FDA says the drug will
come with a warning it can lead to
bleeding in the brain that can be fatal
and medical experts are quick to point
out this is not a cure it's an 18-month
period of the trial we see the group who
receive medication compared to group
recipes the rate of decline was 27
percent less it is a small but there's
still promising when we don't have any
other treatments available
another concern the cost estimated to
cost more than 26 thousand dollars a
year but for the more than 50 million
people estimated to suffer from dementia
worldwide a first a ray of Hope for one
of the darkest of diseases
Patty call Hayne Al Jazeera Washington